we're joined now by the serbian prime
minister anna bernabich good afternoon
to you uh we're just hearing from our
prime minister there boris johnson in
which he was saying that it's entirely a
matter for the australian government but
it is a good idea to be uh vaccinated
hello
hello can you hear me
yes i can we have a little bit of a
technical difficulties just now but we
are fine now i think thank you repeat
what i was saying we just heard from our
prime minister boris johnson and he was
saying that it's entirely a matter for
the australian government regarding
whether um
novak djokovic is allowed to enter
australia to to compete in the
australian open but he was saying that
it is a very good idea to be vaccinated
and i agree with prime minister johnson
i think it is a very good idea to to to
get vaccinated i myself uh
got three uh shots so uh you know inclu
including booster uh shot and uh and as
as the prime minister of the republic of
serbia uh we keep we keep calling on all
of our citizens to to get vaccinated as
for uh nova konovak
uh got a medical exemption uh that is
how he got into the australian open and
then basically got
a permission to participate in the
australian open which is why he's he's
in australia right now
so why is he in this position if the
necessary evidence and paperwork was
sent ahead of time regarding his
exemption
to be honest that's a question for the
australian authorities and and i can't
really get involved uh what what it
matters what matters to me as the prime
minister and to all of serbia is that
this gets resolved as soon as possible
and right now that that novak is not
held in the in the hotel or hostel where
he is in right now but until the final
decision is made that he is in the
isolation fully respecting obviously all
of australian uh uh immigration uh rules
and and health rules but that he is that
that he's uh allowed to stay in in a
place of residence in a house where
which he rented
uh uh where he will be allowed to also
uh train so a house with a tennis court
but that he is not held in the in the
hotel where he is in right now uh i as
the prime minister of serbia i really
don't want to to get involved in in in
the immigration rules in australia but i
i you know we offered all of that all of
the guarantees that novak is transferred
to to that other place uh rather than
staying in the hostel until the final
decision is made
uh we've heard from the serbian
president and uh he's uh described it as
political persecution we we have that on
tape uh well the pr i have to say
firstly the president uh the president
of the republic of serbia mr alexander
vutic is in direct contact with
novak djokovic as well as his family uh
he spoke to him last night he spoke to
him again this morning i'm i'm in touch
with our embassy uh in australia and
obviously the australian embassy here in
belgrade and uh i have also requested if
i can speak directly to the uh to the
minister of the the home affairs uh of
australia um
you know what we don't what we do not
really understand is that
uh the that that uh
you know novak has got a medical
exemption that is why he was he was
allowed to participate in the australian
uh open in the grand slam uh novak also
uh boarded the plane to australia
uh and again you know
all of us know that if you do not have
uh a visa
or uh
you know you do not have
a clearance to enter a country you can't
board the plane especially a plane that
is going all the way to australia uh
and you know other tennis players also
got medical exemption and were allowed
to enter australia and participate
but i don't want to really you know go
into all of the immigration rules in
australia what is important to me right
now is that novak is not in the hostel
or hostel for migrants that he's allowed
to be in isolation until the final
decision is made in the house that he
granted where he could actually be in
the isolation and respect all of the
australia's rules uh that is the only
thing that we're asking for right now
i'm not asking you to uh go into the
details of the the immigration process
in australia but i would like to know
whether you agree with the uh serbian
president when he says that it is
political persecution you yourself say
that you don't understand why
the exemption uh evidence has not been
accepted do you agree that it is
political persecution i can't i i can't
really see anything else uh you know uh
in in this uh i think that the fact is
that novak has been treated differently
uh that you know he got medical
exemption
he was invited to the australia by by
the organizers of the australian open
that he boarded the plane uh with all of
the obvious uh reasons why why he
thought that he could actually enter
australia
and that this is going on now for for
quite some time for uh for for uh more
than several hours
and that uh you know right now he's not
allowed to to
uh
leave and spend time in the house where
he could actually where he could uh
respect the isolation rules so yes i i
you know i think that novak is treated
differently than any other tennis player
that traveled to australia right now and
that is what makes us think it's
political
uh he has in the past been quite opposed
to vaccination on social media his views
are known widely um that can't have done
anything to help his case would you
agree
that that is that is entirely up to
novak uh and i can't i can't and i don't
want to
uh uh advocate for his own personal
viewpoints it has nothing to do with
this i think rules are rules and you
know if
he got medical exemption
which was accepted by the organizers and
all of the health staff at the
australian open
if he was allowed to board the plane
if his whole entire team is is there uh
to to to to present all of the evidence
uh i i really can't see why this is
happening to him and his views
viewpoints are his viewpoints uh and and
i'm not gonna argue for or against them
the australian public have been quite uh
vocal in their disagreement with what
they perceive to be novak djokovic being
treated differently to everybody else by
potentially being allowed to to enter
australia if the court should rule that
he cannot enter australia will you abide
by that decision
well of course but from what i can see
and from what i know there are at least
uh
at least 20 different tennis players
that got medical exemption so they're
not vaccinated they got that medical
exemption so they they they show the
proof why they could not be
vaccinated who entered australia and
will play at the australian open and
novak is the only one who uh got the
medical exemption and is not let uh in
this in in australia so
you know we we will try to do our best
to make sure
uh
novak um
is treated equally uh uh and and gets
all the rights that that he's entitled
to uh that is the only thing i can say
and uh serbia stands by novak i stand by
novak all of our people stand by novak
and his family in these difficult times
and i hope that we will get the
resolution soon and
and in the meantime that that novak
will be able to uh
be in isolation in adequate conditions